getting back to business China's economy
is rebounding after three years of
widespread covid-19 curbs first quarter
GDP grew 4.5 percent beating analysts
expectations the jump was driven by a
surge in consumer spending
during the pandemic it hasn't been easy
to go shopping either in stores or
online but this year people can once
again go out anytime with no more
lockdowns so life is much more
convenient
I just found a new job so now I can make
money again my life is slowly getting
back to normal
it's not Full Speed Ahead just yet
though Factory output was slower than
expected property investment contracted
and unemployment among young people
surged to a near-record high
the government is forecasting that
growth will accelerate in the next three
months but officials say the foundation
for a rebound is not yet solid they say
there are still concerns over domestic
demand and what they're calling a
complicated International environment
economists say one of those
complications is China's relationship
with the rest of the world
China wants to do this transition into
this innovation-based module more
Automation and using more industrial
robots and that requires a significant
input of chips and other high-tech
products and China and U.S relation
isn't getting better anytime soon and
more export ban will pose significant
pressure for Chinese Manufacturing in
general
geopolitical concern has prompted Apple
to reduce its Reliance on Chinese
manufacturing this year its accelerating
operations in India instead analysts say
many companies are looking to diversify
their supply chains but few are ready to
ditch China entirely
is more of a case of I would say Western
companies and institutions hedging their
bets by increasing exposure and sourcing
from other regions rather than a sudden
or a cross-bought exit from China
because
if companies want to take a look at the
balance sheet and the sources of income
really producing from China and selling
to China is still a very attractive
Prospect the international monetary fund
says China will be the top contributor
to Global growth in the next five years
it expects China to account for more
than a fifth of worldwide GDP that's
double the contribution from the United
States the imf's global economic Outlook
is the weakest in 30 years it's urging
countries to avoid political
confrontation and focus on economic
cooperation instead Richard Kimber Al
Jazeera Hong Kong